so I'm currently cleaning house out with
the old and with a new manifesting a new
wardrobe inshah I have no idea how this
is going to look I have contractual
obligations clothes to wear post to
do brothers and sister just imagine for
a second that you give £10 in donation
and that £10 is used to buy food or
bricks or whatever to help the people in
Gaza but then just imagine this amazing
D that you want to do but we turn it
into a money-making machine how the walk
is exactly that they take your money and
the money that we are going to put in in
this W this building and every single
time the money generated from that W
that building is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sisters for the
next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years and
this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subh bless and preserve you
guys asalam Alum guys hope you guys are
well in so you guys might know and not
know of Britney Rena I that's I don't I
don't know nothing about her I'll be
honest with the only time that I know of
her is when she was on a podcast on just
ply with Andrew Tate and herself who was
on the left hand side speaking about
these matters aldah and recently a video
was sent to me of her in hijab saying
inshallah talking about a new wardrobe
Etc I don't know nothing about her for
that matter but apparently she was
dating a famous footballer that's all I
know for that matter she got a big
follow on Instagram but she was in hijab
and here's what she had to say and then
we're going to read some comments and
see is she mocking the hijab or is she a
real Muslim we're going going to see
what Islam says on this matter for
somebody who is coming out with the
Garment of the muslim's attire which is
the hijab here is what she had to say we
want the sign to be on the billboard in
Big Red Letters lit up with glitter and
it's almost as if we're waiting for this
moment to feel ready you're not going to
feel ready for something you've never
done that's why you have to get pushed
we and we're also waiting for us to
trust the outside world and the people
in it but a bird doesn't trust the
branch it lands on it trusts it's wings
and you should do the same so I'm
currently cleaning house out with the
old in with the new manifesting a new
wardrobe inshah I have no idea how this
is going to look I have contractual
obligations clothes to wear post to do
bills that have to be paid showing up
the best I can right cuz I know that
it's not going to be perfect I know that
people may have a grip I my arms are out
right first of all was hot and then I
sweat like a puddle under my armpits not
an excuse but looking into Botox under
my arms and finding clothes that are
more aligned with where I'm headed even
if it's not to the book perfect that's
what this is all about for me is I'm
just going to show up and give my best
and every day my best gets better so
guys you saw for yourself those videos
interesting points she me and I want to
touch on one of them when she talks
about the the bird trust the wings not
the branch that it sits on and I thought
that's very very important because I
want to touch upon obviously herself
when it comes to having trust in Allah
what does this mean at the same time I
also want to send her a guided pray from
our organization our charity that will
teach you how to pray step by step it's
absolutely free you guys can order as
well uh our orders are closed at the
moment cuz we have 6 and half th000
orders so Salah plus.com is coming
really soon soon in with our new app
that will teach you how to pray Salah it
has a free guided u a free k finder your
local Salah times Etc anyways so one
thing I want to say before I get to
talking about that is the comments what
does the comment say so we had a comment
here from Tony Shinji whatever his name
is he says it's interesting how as a
Christian who served in the in
Afghanistan as a US Marine feel offended
by you using this as a fashion stat or
some sort of a life change like what's
the purpose cuz you can't be exposing
your skin can't be wearing makeup you
can't talk disrespectful of men like do
you know the realities of being a Muslim
woman okay let's find out like it must
be nice in America but in the Middle
East you are forbidden to get an
education above the sixth grade this is
nonsense nowhere in Islam does it say
that a woman cannot get education yeah
the first University was built by a
Muslim woman called Fatima you are
forbidden to get an education only get
discipline on your daughters this is a
lie in Islam it very clearly tells you
that a man and a woman should not have
sex before marriage a man and a woman
who commits adult the capital punishment
the same a man or woman who steals the
the same punishment the punishment
exactly the same there is nothing inam
that says there's one rule for a woman
and another rule for a man when it comes
to those kind of stuff your husband does
Sons and Daughters if he's around I
don't know what that means you you
aren't allowed to drive or have your own
bank account this nonsense it's not from
Islam a the prophet P his wife had a her
own camel your camel are equivalent to
cars so that's absolute nonsense having
not having a passort bank account it's
nonsense you can't have that um any
income you have goes to your husband
this absolutely bull crap it's actually
the opposite way around because anything
that I earn is for my family and
anything that I gave my wife as a do Mah
or her personal money is hers so it's
that the opposite opposite way so please
educate yourself you don't talk to other
men who aren your family or husband du I
mean would you want your wife talking to
what's your name let's see your name uh
Tony would you like your wife going and
speaking to random guys are you
comfortable with that are you okay no
you're not deep down you hate it yeah
okay so it looks like you you really
hate it you would rather have your wife
call following Islam than any other
thing then we've got people saying this
is from God is glamorous Jesus is Lord
babe Muhammad is dead turn to Jesus the
one true king he is alive and he's
waiting for you to return with open arms
read John 81 la la Etc uh firstly babe
yes okay Jesus is Lord how is Jesus lord
Jesus never ever claimed to be God and
Muhammad is dead yes he died I mean it's
very interesting you say a prophet is
dead he can't be a prophet but yet alone
you believe Jesus God of the your God
died on the cross which one's worth a
prophet dying or God dying yeah okay
anyways um again you got someone here
called vami where it's called give your
life to Jesus not a false god I'm proud
that you are changing your lifestyle but
yeah who's who's who Jesus Jesus
worshiped God Almighty he all he worship
God he never claimed to be divine so I
don't know what you guys are talking
about here let's go to the next one so
there's some other different comments
here which is just because you change
your religion does it mean your body
counts changes now this is firstly
disrespectful and disgusting to even
accuse any woman for that matter and who
cares in Islam a woman or a man who has
had sex outside of marriage slept with
many other people whatever is for the
matter yes are there consequences
psychologically mentally yes there might
be however that in Islam we believe that
you do not bring that stuff up and you
keep it away it's done and dusted okay
to talk about her body count and this Ty
Etc in Islam when you accept Islam all
your sins are forgiven not only that
your sins are turned into Good Deeds
it's a clean slate you are brand new
simple as that now if people want to go
into yes the psychological effects on a
woman having mult multiple sexual
partners that's a different story we're
not talking denying those facts but
we're seeing that the sins are changed
and somebody wrote you U Amber r on
Whose midli Crist is better so people
are just like mocking her etc for that
matter baby girl you got to get rid of
the other pigs and videos if you're in
this for real now this is where I want
to touch about the thing that you
mentioned okay this way I want to touch
upon you said that the bird trust is
Wings not the not the branch that it
lays uh it sits on which is important
meaning if the branch breaks it relies
on what its wings with art is similar
analogy in a different way we put our
trust in Allah subhana tala so one thing
I want to say to you my dear sister
Britney I don't know if you'll be
watching this or not is the following
when I went on your page obviously I
have no idea of your page I know nothing
about it when I went there obviously I
was in a bit of shock you know cuz at
the end of the day yes you're wearing
the hijab but I realized obviously first
impression of that page was you've got
nearly all of your pictures are of you
dressed half naked um and one thing I
just want to say is the foll my de
sister a lot of and I want to recommend
a book to you called Beauty sick the
sickness of beauty that is affecting
Millions if not billions of women out
there that you rely on your looks your
body parts your I don't want to get into
details whatever it is what happens is
Islam has come to uplift you from the
reason why you wear the hijab and the
correct way of hijab is obviously you
don't beautify yourself is why and
everyone has their struggles and you're
going to have those struggles is the
following Islam has come to make you a
human being that people talk to you and
do not talk to something else because
when you are covered you are not judged
by your sexuality but you are judged by
you as a person the person talking to
you is talking to you not talking to
someone else and as men our weakness is
the opposite gender because we are told
that that's the reason why you say
that's why the people say that a woman
falls for what she hears and a man falls
for what he sees that's the reason why
women wear makeup and the reason why men
lie so which shows that we have
different weakness and different
perspectives so that's why Islam is said
for a woman to cover a beauty so that it
elevates her now why not that this
misconception that women should cover up
cuz men can't control theel there's
nothing like that in Islam you everyone
has their modesty I as a Muslim man have
to cover from my Naval to my knee the
point is this though when you heavily
rely on your looks and Beauty you need
to understand there's going to come a
point where there is no Botox nothing
that you're going to do that's going to
make you look more beautiful there's
going to be a decline it be it's
biologically by your age or whatever it
is for that matter so you need to
understand when you're talking about
relying on your wings we have that
Reliance on God Almighty you could cover
up in a way then nobody sees you and God
Almighty will send you a man that is
good for you and you can show your body
and you will have thousands if not
millions of drooling desperate perverted
men who are after you for the wrong
things that's the reason why if you
think about it something an item that is
cheap like in in in in the UK we have
somewhere called Prim up it's quite
cheap I there's nothing wrong with it ey
shop there as well but there's so many
you know buyers Etc but when you want to
go and buy a Bugatti yeah and I'm not
trying to compare woman to cars but what
I'm saying is the following not
everybody can go and get a Bugatti not
even if you're wealthy they're going to
come and see you ask who are you what's
your status we're not just going to give
you a car to anybody that's the way in
Islam Islam honors a woman when I
married my wife had to speak to her
father had to give her a diary had to do
a wedding have to announce the wedding I
have to give her rights why because to
show that I honor her imagine she was
someone who just like anybody can have
access to Left Right Center that's the
reason why Islam has come to honor woman
the hijab is not just what you wear it's
what comes out your mouth it's how you
conduct yourself so what I want to say
is if you inshallah come to a stage
where Iman comes that's Faith enters
your heart properly is that you will
understand your Reliance will be for God
Almighty you don't need to show your
body parts to make money to show
yourself Etc in a revealing way so you
can attract men once you devote yourself
to God and have those wings that you
rely on which is God Almighty Allah will
give you a way out from places you can
never imagine which he says in the Quran
if you fear me fearing means what having
acknowledgement of him doing abstaining
from things that is deemed Haram and
doing things that is deemed Halal then
you will see that Allah subhana tal just
like he gives and Allah mentions in the
Quran gives the birds Allah says they
leave their nest empty stomach and come
back with a full stomach so the bird and
that you gave would be what Allah will
give you those wings that will get you
through all the hardships in life that's
all I wanted to say inshah for you guys
watching and our sister Britney is that
inshallah we would love to as a team to
send you and many people like you a
guided free mat inah Salah plus.com like
I said orders are closed at the moment
because we' got a large amount of orders
but if there's anyone specific new to
Islam we will send and we would like to
send one to you get in contact with our
team at admin salamor do.uk till next
time may Allah preserve you and one
thing I want to say for those who are
questioning oh is she mocking or not
look that's she's only harming herself I
don't know what she is we assume the
best she's seem that she's a Muslim we
take it from face value and that's what
we have to say until she proves
otherwise then we'll deal with that M
then till next time